- Hello.
I love software deployments.
I love software deployments because
it's how I deliver value
to you, my customers,
and I see that you're here today.
You probably also love deploying software
to also bring value to your customers.
My name's Kevin Gibbs,
and I'm here with my colleague Mike Rizzo,
and we're gonna talk
through ECS deployments,
and some of the advanced
deployment strategies
that we've delivered this year.
Just a rundown of what we're
gonna run through today.
First we're gonna talk
through just a primer
of ECS services and deployments.
Mike is gonna go through a deep dive
on advanced deployment
techniques, configuration,
and what exactly we mean when
we say advanced deployments.
Finally, we're gonna go
through some choosing
and migrating between
different deployment strategies
or two advanced deployments from rolling.
And we'll also cover some key takeaways,
and some other ways that you can finish
and continue your learning process.
So first off, when we
talk about ECS services,
we're really talking about
two different configuration parameters,
or sets of parameters.
The first one is your task definition.
So task definition defines a unit of work,
a single task within a service.
And then service configuration
in those parameters,
say how you want to deploy one
or more of those tasks
to perform some function.
Those two things together,
those combination
actually come down,
and result in a service
revision is what we call an ACS,
so you can actually look at
how your service changes over time
by looking through your revision history.
The process from going from either nothing
to your first service revision
or from a service revision
to your next service revision
is an ECS deployment.
And that process is what
we're gonna go over today.
What it does, how it works,
and some of the configuration of it.
So to get into a sum of the configuration
for your deployments, the
first thing that we look at
is the deployment controller.
So today we're gonna be focusing on
the ECS deployment controller,
our native controller
that we manage for you.
There are two other options that you have.
One is you can use Code Deploy,
which also supports
some blue/green, Linear
and Canary, as well as external.
And what external means
is really it's up to you.
You own the deployments, you
can do it however you want,
but you are taking on that responsibility,
so it is another option.
Again, we're gonna focus
on ECS going forward.
So the next thing you need
to decide is what strategy.
So now that you have your
controller decided on ECS,
we have four strategies.
We have our default
strategy which is rolling,
where you're deploying a new service
alongside your old revision,
and you're just migrating via the creation
and deletion of tasks.
In contrast to that,
you also have three new
advanced deployment controls,
or deployment strategies, sorry.
These are different in sort of
how traffic is migrated,
but all of them allow you
to have a new set of tasks,
and an old set of tasks sitting together
to allow you to roll back,
and roll forward much more quickly
and seamlessly between versions.
Some of the differences that you'll notice
between standard rolling
and advanced deployments
is what your task capacity looks like.
So in a standard rolling deployment
you're actually gonna create new task,
and delete or stop old tasks.
And so you kind of have
more of a constant capacity.
Whereas, in advanced deployments,
through the lifetime of your deployment
you're actually gonna have
double the number of tasks.
You're gonna have your blue task
and your green task if you
wanna use the color analogy.
And so you have, again,
twice for that duration.
And then you go back down to normal
once the deployment is over.
The other aspect, key differences is
how traffic is shifted or
transitions between the two.
So in blue/green, you
have, again, blue task
and green tasks running
right next to each other,
old and new.
And so the total traffic
that goes to either one
is basically dependent on how
many tasks are up and healthy.
In advanced deployments you
have additional functionality
of how that traffic is shifted,
and so in blue/green,
really what that's doing is
taking 100% from blue to green.
One step, we just do it once.
Canary is kind of a two-step process.
So you get to choose
the initial percentage.
So, in this case I'm showing
10% is the initial transition,
and so you transition 10% of your traffic.
Then you can check metrics,
make sure everything's looking good,
and then it'll transition 100%.
Linear is an end-stage version,
and so in this one you have increments.
And so you can start with as small as 3%,
which would result in about
33 stages to your deployment,
but it does traffic shifting over time.
And so some of the reasons
you would want to do that
is if you're concerned about performance
of the new version,
and so you wanna actually
gradually shift traffic,
and see how it's performing,
or something like that.
Some of the common configuration
that you have between all
of the ECS strategies
are life cycle hooks.
So this was something new
that we added this year.
And this is the ability for you to engage
in the deployment process.
You can define your lambdas
of hey, after you've
scaled up my new tasks
I want to do something.
I wanna check something or whatever.
You can also implement your
own traffic shifting paradigm
via life cycle.
And then also we have
the idea of a bake time.
So if you're using alarm-based rollbacks,
which we've had for a little while.
If you want to just bake
it with that new version
surfing traffic for an hour a day,
you have that option with the bake time.
Finally, there's some
specific configuration
for the different strategies.
The first one is with rolling is kind of
how those increments grow
and shift over time of
what is your total max
capacity in rolling,
and then also what's a minimum capacity.
And so you can actually have
it scale down some tasks
before it starts new tasks,
or start new tasks before
scaling down old tasks,
configured using those two things.
Blue/green, there's
really nothing specific.
You can set up the life cycle hooks,
and you can set up your bake time,
but it's pretty much just a single shift,
so there's nothing specific.
With canary you can
control that initial shift,
and you can go as small as 0.1%,
and you can go all the way up to 99.9%
to kind of control how much traffic
is on your new version
before you move everyone over to it.
And then Linear, similarly,
each stage can be
as small as 3%,
and as much as 99.9%.
And, again, with those last two,
you kind of have a time wait,
kind of like a mini bake time
between each of your shifts to control.
Now I'm gonna hand it off to Mike,
as he's gonna deep dive into the different
advanced deployment strategies.
(people chattering)
- Thanks, Kevin, for that great intro
to advanced deployments.
My name's Mike,
and (indistinct) say
I'm really excited about
working with customers to help them
derive real benefits from new features
like advanced deployments.
Over the next half hour or so,
I'm gonna a bit deeper into
how advanced deployments work.
And also look at some specific examples
of how you can use them in a variety
of different scenarios.
But first a little detour.
Just like to share another
passion of mine, unicorns.
So at AWS we love unicorns.
I'll let you in on a little secret.
Some of us venture out at night
looking to spot one of
these amazing creatures,
and here's one that a colleague
of mine snapped last week.
And the reason I'm
mentioning this is because
I'd like to take you through a journey
that one of my favorite
customers recently went through
with advanced deployments.
Meet Ada, CTO of Unicorn Watch.
So Unicorn Watch is the
world's leading expository
of unicorn sightings data,
the go-to place for unicorn research.
It's also home to the
world's largest archive
of unicorn sighting videos.
And when Ada heard about
advanced deployments being launched,
she came to us and asked
whether there was anything
that they could benefit
from using advanced deployments
to speed up their delivery velocity.
So this is the architecture they had
prior to advanced
deployments coming along.
They had a UI fronted with an ALB,
and through this UI users were able to
access a catalog of videos,
to access their accounts,
and to make purchases.
When making a purchase, that would trigger
the creation of an order fulfillment flow,
and the flow could be
monitored through another ALB
by pulling an interface
on orders serviced.
All the interaction between the front end,
and the back end was
through Service Connect.
And then they also had the bottom,
an (indistinct) streaming service
that would pick up videos
from a media asset bucket.
And the way this worked as well was
the way that orders
would be creating videos
that were water marked
with a unique identifier
for security purposes.
So this all worked nicely,
and they were using ECS
rolling deployments throughout
with one exception.
In the case of the UI they
wanted to use blue/green
so they could manually
check any new deployments
in a safe enviornment
before flipping it over
into the production environment.
For that they use Code Deploy.
Okay, so, you can imagine
that a service like this,
it's a premium service
with a high price tag,
and also those unicorn photographers
wanna get their royalties
so it's really important
that this platform maintains
a high level of availability
and reliability.
At the same time,
there's growing demand
for more new features,
and also Ada wanted to
expose the catalog service
to third party websites
so that they could also resell
videos from the catalog.
So the challenge they faced
was they wanted to maintain
high variability and reliability,
but at the same time speed
up their delivery velocity.
So when advanced deployments came along
they were really keen to understand
what that could do for them.
So, I come back to this story in a second,
but first I just wanna take you through
the life cycle of an advanced deployment
in a bit more detail.
So, in the initial state,
we have a service running in production.
Record is the blue environment.
All traffic is going there,
and when we start a new
deployment we have new spec
for the tasks that need to be run,
including a new (indistinct), for example.
And we enter the deployment state machine
in the first stage,
which is noticed pre-scale up.
So this is before we scale
up the green enviornment.
Now you see that there's
a little hook icon
on the side there.
That notes that this is a hookable stage,
which means that you can
attach a lifecycle hook to it.
So with lifecycle hooks you
can run your own custom logic
in a lambda function,
and you can use that to perform tests
or checks that you could use to determine
whether you want that stage to proceed,
to succeed and proceed to the next stage,
or whether you want to force a roll back.
In this example, before you
scale up the green enviornment,
you might, for example,
want to run some kind of
admission control check where
you might say, for example,
is this container image coming from
a trusted repo?
So if the hook returns successfully,
you then proceed to the next stage,
and this is where we do the scale up.
So, yeah, we scale up
the green enviornment.
You can see there on the far side
we have the green enviornment scaling up.
And once you achieve the full scale up
then we went the post-scale up stage.
At this point, all production traffic
is still going to the blue environment,
there's no traffic going
to green environment.
So once we've got the
green enviornment in place,
the next step is start
shifting test traffic to it.
So we now enter the test
traffic shift stage,
and here we configure routing
so that test traffic,
which has to be identified in some way,
we'll come back to that later,
that test traffic can start to flow
to the green enviornment.
Once that routing is set up,
we enter the post test
traffic shift stage.
Now, at this point the green enviornment
is able to start to receive test traffic.
This is a really convenient
place to put in some hooks
if you want to do
some automated testing
on the green enviornment,
or if you want some kind of manual check,
some manual approval on something
running in the green environment,
you can do that through the hook here.
And we're gonna see some examples of this
with Unicorn Watch,
and see how they use this.
Okay, so we're now at the position where
the blue environment's still
receiving all production traffic,
all test traffic is going to green.
Once we exit the post
traffic shift successfully,
so any life cycle hooks have succeeded,
we can start to shift
the production traffic
to the green enviornment.
Now, depending on the
strategy you're using,
this can happen in a
number of different ways.
The simplest is with blue/green
this happens all at once.
So we shift all traffic in one step
from blue to green.
But can also do Canary,
where you have it in two stages,
or you can do it Linear,
which could be multi-step.
We'll come back to that shortly.
Once you've shifted production traffic,
and you've got 100% going to green,
we enter the post production
traffic shift stage.
Now at this point there's
no more production traffic
going to blue, it's all going to green,
but the blue enviornment is still running.
We still have the old
service revision running
in the blue enviornment.
And this is useful because
it means that if something
was going wrong in the green enviornment,
we can very quickly roll back
and switch back to the blue one.
And we keep this blue enviornment running
for a defined bake time.
So as part of your configuration
for the blue/green deployment
you can specify a bake time.
And for the whole
duration of the bank time
your blue enviornment
will continue to exist.
Once the base time is over,
the final step is clean up.
At this point we scale
the blue down to zero,
and we now have a
situation where the green
is our production enviornment,
and becomes the blue enviornment
for the next deployment.
Each of these stages
can take up to 24 hours,
so you can do this over a
pretty long period of time,
if you need to run long
tests, for example.
You'll also notice I was
careful not to say too much
about how the routing,
and the traffic shifting
is actually happening,
and that was deliberate
because it depends on how
the service is exposed.
So, for example, if the service
is behind the load balancer,
then it's achieved by manipulating
waits or listener rules.
But if the service is
exposed to Service Connect,
then the routing is
achieved through changing
the routing rules in the
service connect proxy.
So in the case of Canary deployment,
everything's exactly the same
as we saw in the lifecycle up until now.
The only difference is
you get two production
traffic shift stages.
So essentially any hooks
attached to production traffic shift,
that hook will be invoked twice.
First time will be for
the initial Canary shift.
So in the first step
you take a percentage,
ion this case we've got 10%
but you can configure that.
And we specify a Canary bake time.
And for the duration of
that Canary bake time,
we will have that percentage
of production traffic
going to the green enviornment.
Once the Canary bake time is over,
production, traffic shift is entered again
so we invoke the hook
again if there is one.
And then that completes
the rest of the traffic
shift to production.
In the case of Linear, it's similar.
But we have multiple steps.
So you can use Canary
and Linear to achieve
different objectives.
In the case of Canary,
you would, if had a
situation where you wanted
to do some testing of
your new service revision
with actual production traffic
you can do that with Canary,
limiting your blast radius
so that if things went wrong
it wouldn't hit you too badly.
In the case of Linear,
what it allows you to do
is have a more gradual
sort of roll out of the
new service revision
while you're monitoring to make sure
that any performance
and functionality is maintained correctly.
Really important that when
using advanced deployment
you think about what
would constitute a failure
or under performance of the new revision
that would require you
to stop the deployment
and roll back.
And ECS provides three broad
mechanisms to support this.
First, the simplest is Circuit Breaker.
So with Circuit Breaker
you're simply checking
that the new tasks actually
achieve a healthy, stable state
within a specified time period.
Next we've got card watch alarms.
So here you can choose metrics
that are appropriate for your use case,
and set alarms on those metrics,
and if those alarms are triggered
then that can force a failure,
and a roll back of the deployment.
The metrics you can use here.
It depends, for example, if
you have an ALB fronted service
you might be looking at
metrics for counts of 400
or 500 errors.
If you had benchmarked the performance
or prevision revisions,
and you want to ensure
that the performance
of the new revision
is consistent with what you had previously
you might want to be looking
at things like CPU utilization
or memory utilization.
Very important that you factor in,
if you're using Canary or Linear in that
there's a mixture of the green
and blue running together,
so that is something you
need to take account of
in your alarm thresholds.
You can also think
about certain situations
where you have a task that's
pulling messages off a cue,
so there's no traffic that should be
rooted to the task,
but instead the task's
pulling messages off a cue.
In that case you might want to
be monitoring your cue length
as a metric for alarming.
And then finally we've got custom tasks
and traffic monitoring.
And this is where
life cycle hooks I
mentioned earlier come in.
This is where you can implement
your own tests in Lambda,
and insert them at the right places
in the deployment life cycle.
And we're gonna see some
more examples of this
with Unicorn Watch.
So, let's go back to
Unicorn Watch architecture.
So, just a refresher that this is
the architecture they had
prior to advanced deployments.
And what I'm gonna do
now is just go through
some aspects of this architecture in turn,
and see what changes they make,
and what they were able
to achieve through that.
So first we're gonna talk about the UI
and the catalog service.
So they wanted to do a
couple of things here.
They wanted to switch to
using Canary deployments
for the catalog so they could
try using the new Function F catalog
in production enviornment
with a limited blast radius.
And they also wanted to expose the catalog
on a public API so that
third party websites
could also access it.
Now, they couldn't do this
sticking with Code Deploy
because first Code Deploy
doesn't support Service Connect,
so they couldn't use it
with a catalog for Canaries,
but also what they wanted
to do to expose the public,
the catalog on a public API
is they wanted to expose it
on the same load balancer,
and on the same port.
And to do that they would need to use
the load balancers advanced
request routine capabilities
to use path-based routing.
With Code Deploy you can't
do path-based routing.
So by moving to ECS blue/green,
they were able to achieve
their objective, right?
So essentially what you can see here is
they were able to use plot-based routing
to access two different services
through the same port on ALB,
and also switch to Canary
on the catalog service.
So let's look into this
with a bit more detail,
starting with the load balancer.
What I'm gonna do with this diagram,
we'll come back to this diagram
as we go through the talk.
I'm gonna go through a
number of different ways
of exposing services on ECS,
and show you how advanced deployments work
with each of them.
So we're starting here
with the load balancer.
So when you do advanced
deployments with ALB,
you need to provide as a minium
a production listener rule.
And optionally a test listener rule.
And the way it works is
essentially the waits
on those listener rules are manipulated by
the ECS deployment controller to achieve
the traffic shifting effects
that we talked about previously.
Because ALB works at
the listener rule level
it is possible to take full advantage
of advanced request routing
on the application load balancer,
which means you can still
do path-based routing,
you can header-based routing,
(indistinct) base rounding,
all these features that
you've come to expect with ALB
can still be supported.
You can also make the
same service available
in multiple listeners as well,
and that will also work
with advanced deployments.
In order to configure this in
your service configuration,
in the load balancer block,
you would add this advanced
configuration block,
and here you specify
a second target group.
So you now need a second target group
in order for the advanced
deployments to work.
And then you specify a
production listener ARN,
optionally a test listener rule ARN,
and importantly also an IM roll,
and the IM roll is needed
to give ECS permission
to manipulate the waits
on those listener rules.
Notes that there's no
reference to a listener ARN,
and that means you are free to choose
any listener rules you like,
whether they are on the same port or not.
From an ECS perspective it
doesn't make any difference.
So ECS is agnostic to which ports
those listener rules are
actually connected to.
So let's walk through how this works,
taking the example of Unicorn Watchers UI.
So they want to do a
blue/green deployment,
and they want to do a manual
approval on the new version
before they allow it
to go into production.
So in the starting state,
they have the existing service
running in the blue environment,
and all traffic is going to that.
First step is we do the scale up,
so we create the green service revision,
we go to the pre-scale up,
scale up, post scale up stages.
We then start to shift (indistinct).
So to shift (indistinct) we need to,
on the test listener we
swap the waits around.
So we now have 100%
of traffic going into
the green environment.
At this point, once the
traffic shift is completed
we're going to post the traffic shift,
and in this case Unicorn
Watch have attached a hook,
and what this hook does is
it monitors an approval parameter,
(audience applauding)
until this approval parameter
is set to accept or decline.
So something somewhere
needs to set that parameter
in order to be picked
up by life cycle hook
to determine whether or not
the deployment should proceed.
Know that ECS itself does not provide AUI
to do manual approval
or anything like that.
That implementation is
up to the implementer
of the wider operations,
and how you orchestrate operations
around deployments in your organization.
In this example, we've just used
an approval parameter
stored in a parameter store,
and then there's a separate
UI that can be used
for an approver to go in,
and set that parameter.
The way the traffic shift,
the post traffic shift hook works here
is it checks for the current
state of approval parameter.
If it's still in a pending state,
the hook returns with an in-progress
status indicator.
An ECS will then reinvoke
the hook multiple times
until a success or failure is returned.
Okay, assuming then that
we got the approval,
we got a tick in the box so
the hook is able to succeed,
and we're now able to
progress the deployment
beyond the post S traffic shift stage,
so now we can move to
production traffic shifts.
Here we swap the weights
on the production rule,
and we start our clock for bake time.
So during this time we
now have traffic flowing
to the green environment,
but with the blue still waiting
just in case we need to roll back.
And then, finally, assuming
we complete bake time
without rolling back, the
last stage is cleanup,
so that's where we
scale down the old blue,
and the green becomes the new blue.
Okay, so that's how Unicorn Watch used
the ALB in front of their UI service,
now using ECS blue/green.
We haven't talked about
the actual request route,
we're talking about traffic shifting.
Now, remember I said
that they also wanted
to expose the catalog
on the same ALB port.
So how do they want to achieve this?
They want to do this
with path-based routing.
So what they set up, as you can see here,
is a path-based route
for catalog/catalog star,
routing to the catalog service,
another one front-end start to UI service.
They also needed a way to
indicate test traffic, right?
If you have test traffic for
either of those services,
how do you indicate that
this is test traffic?
For that they chose to
use Hoda-based routing.
So if there is an XGB test header,
that signals that the
traffic is test traffic.
And they can do this because
they can use advanced request routing
with advanced deployments.
So here we have, you can see
two rules for production,
catalog production listener rule,
and UI production listener rule.
The application load
balancer with a path pattern
matching catalog and front end to route
to each of those rules.
And then on the far side there you can see
the deployment control has
been configured directly
to manipulate those rules.
In the case of catalog,
using Canary deployment,
and in the case of UI using blue/green.
In order to route the test traffic,
we have another two listener rules,
and we've added the HTTP header rules
matches onto those rules as well.
Important to order your
rules in the right order
in order to get the desired effect.
Okay.
What about Service Connect?
So we've looked at the ALB,
but catalog is also exposed
internally via Service Connect.
And we want that Canary to
work with Service Connect?
So how does that work?
So with Service Connect
there's no listener rules,
and no waits in listener
rules to manipulate.
Instead, we have the Service Connect proxy
sitting alongside the
application container
in the applications task,
and that leads to route
traffic to the right place.
So the way it works is you've got your,
you create your greener vision,
and both your blue and greener visions
are registered with Cloud Map,
with the green one being
labeled as your test instance.
All clients in the main space,
in the Service Connect
name space can see both,
the blue and the green revisions.
But only requests matching the test routes
we routed to the green revision.
For those of you may not be
familiar with Service Connect,
in a nutshell, the way it works is
you have your proxy
container running alongside
your application container and your task,
and that is configured to route,
basically all network
traffic passes through
that proxy container,
and it can be configured
through outbound traffic
to the version that you require.
The way it's setup by default
is if you set the header
(indistinct) ECS blue/green test,
then Service Connect
proxy will automatically
route that to the green revision.
You can replace that with
your own header routing rules.
You can use any headers you like.
You can use header presence,
header value matching,
header pattern matching so you can
use things like agent strings
or API revision numbers, et. cetera,
as needed in your use case.
So how did Unicorn use this?
So the catalog team wanted,
they were very concerned
about performance,
and they wanted to make sure
they do performance tests
on any new revision of the service
before putting it into production.
So, basically they implemented
this using two things.
They put a traffic generator
in the Service Connect main space.
And this traffic generator generates load,
and all the requests
are automatically marked
with a test header.
They then implemented hook
in the post S traffic shift stage.
And what they do in this
stage is they trigger
the load generator to
start sending test traffic,
they measure the performance
of the service under load,
and then at the end of that test,
they determine whether it's passed or not.
If it's passed, the hook
returned successfully,
and the deployment continues,
otherwise (indistinct).
A key thing to note here is that
if you are doing testing
with Service Connect
your client has to be
part of the Service Connect name space,
you can't test from outside.
You have do it from
within Service Connect.
In this case they
achieved that by deploying
this traffic generator in the
Service Connect name space.
Okay, so that gave them a performance test
in the green enviornment
before moving into the
production traffic shift.
But even when going into
production traffic shift,
they wanted to use the Canary
to do some additional testing
before allowing the full shift
of production traffic
into the new enviornment.
So here, if you remember
I mentioned earlier
that with Canary the
production traffic shift hook
will get invoked twice.
So what I did here was
on the first invocation
they start a test.
So at this point a percentage,
a Canary percentage
of production traffic is going
to the green enviornment,
and we start this test to start monitoring
the performance of the Canary.
That continues for the duration
of the Canary bake time.
And at the end of the Canary bake time,
post production, the
production traffic shift hook
is called for the second time,
and at this point the
results of the monitoring
are collected,
and analyzed to determine
whether the Canary
has performed successfully or not.
And, once again, if the Canary
has performed successfully
we allow (indistinct) success,
and allow this production traffic shift
to complete to 100%.
But if not we can force a roll back
by failing the hook.
So this shows you that
you can combine testing
of the green environment,
as we saw in the previous slide,
with also testing with some of the traffic
in actual production through the Canary
production traffic shift mechanism.
Okay, so we looked at the UI,
and the Catalog so far.
The next thing they looked at
was this mechanism here,
with a polling (indistinct)
application advancer
for the status of orders
that are underway.
Now this doesn't scale very well, right?
Essentially you're having
to pull for status updates,
and obviously the more orders
you have going through,
the less efficient this becomes.
But also from a notification
mechanism perspective,
this was quite limiting as well.
What I wanted to do was support
different notification mechanisms like
if people wanted to receive an email
or an SMS on their phone,
or whatever notification mechanism,
they wanted to support a wide range,
and they couldn't do it
with this architecture.
What I wanted to do is switch
to a more asynchronous approach
where orders would post events on a cue,
and then that cue would be,
essentially would be monitored
by a notification service
that would pull events off the cue,
and then serve notifications
using a variety of mechanisms
as configured for each user.
And the problem is they
couldn't do that easily
because if they did that
they would need a blue/green deployment
in order to be able to switch
from one version to another
in one step,
and they couldn't do that with Code Deploy
because this service wouldn't have
a load balancer in front of it
if it was pulling messages from a cue.
So that's what I want it to do.
There's no load balancer in front of
the notification service.
This is what we call a headless service.
There's no request actually being sent
to the notification service.
(indistinct) service pulling
messages off the cue.
And with ECS blue/green,
again, you can support this pattern.
So you can support headless services,
where there's no Service Connect,
there's no load balancer,
you just have a task
or a service pulling messages off a cue.
So this is the next pattern
we're gonna look at, headless service.
Now, with headless service,
because there's no request
being sent to the service,
there's no traffic to shift,
so you might ask how does this make sense
for advanced deployments if
there's no traffic to shift.
It only makes sense in the sense that
you can still, if you still benefit from
having a blue and green enviornment
running in parallel for a while
so that if the green doesn't work well,
and you need to roll back quickly,
you can still roll back
very quickly to the blue enviornment.
However, because there
is no request traffic,
you have to think a bit differently
about how you manage the
activation of these services.
So essentially you need
to do a bit of extra work
to determine which version of the service
is picking messages off the cue.
And you need some way of turning off,
turning on or off the actual services,
pulling off messages off the cue.
So let's see how it
worked for Unicorn Watch.
So, in the initial state of
the existing blue revision,
pulling messages off the cue,
and processing those messages,
they now deploy a new version.
When they deployed a new version,
they deploy it in a deactivated state.
So the tasks are created,
but there is some parameter,
perhaps in parameter store, for example,
which is controlling whether or not
this thing should pull
things off the cue or not.
So it starts in a deactivated state saying
don't pull messages off the cue.
Once this is scaled up,
we can skip the usual test traffic shift,
you can just go straight through that,
go straight to production traffic shift.
And at this point,
when we enter this stage,
we can use a hook to
disable the blue revision,
and enable the green revision.
So at this point it's
now the green revision
that's picking up messages from the cue
and processing them.
And at this point we start
to monitor the behavior
and the performance of the green revision,
and make sure that it is
functioning correctly,
and processing messages correctly.
So, we monitor this case using Cloud Watch
to monitor the cue.
If monitoring is successful
(indistinct) succeeded,
and we can get rid of the blue revision
after the bake time.
Otherwise, if unsuccessful
we disable green,
and restore the blue,
reactivate the blue to go back
to where they were previously.
So that's improved their
ability to notify customers
on status updates for orders.
The last bit was the video
streaming service itself.
And here they wanted the ability
to deploy new versions
of their proprietary streaming protocol
with a lot of new security features,
and they needed to do it in such a way
that they flipped completely
from one version to another
because they couldn't
guarantee computability
between the new version
and the old version.
So they wanted blue/green on
the video streaming service,
and to do this they used
advanced deployments
with a network load balancer.
With network load balancer,
it's very similar in many ways
to what we saw with
application load balancer,
but there are some differences
you need to be aware of.
First, with network load balancer,
at the moment you can only do blue/green,
you cannot do Canary or Linear.
Second, you don't have
the benefit of layer
seven request routing,
because you're working at layer four,
so you can't do path-based routing.
That means you have to use different ports
for your production and tests.
So you need to have separate ports
for production and tests.
And also the test listener is not optional
in the case of NLB.
You must have a test listener.
The other thing to be aware
of is that for some stages
there's an extra 10 minute delay added on,
and this is to do with some of
the internal climbing issues
within NLB to make sure the
routing works correctly.
But otherwise it's quite similar to ALB.
So, just to recap, we saw
here how Unicorn Watch
were able to use advanced deployments
in a number of different areas.
And what we've done essentially
is cover four different
service exposure methods.
We've looked at ALB,
we've looked at Service Connect,
we looked at headless services,
and we looked at NLB.
And the beauty of advanced deployments
is you can use advanced deployments
with all of these service
exposure patterns.
And with that I'll hand back to Kevin,
he's gonna take you through
some of the practicalities
around migration,
and how you choose your
deployment strategy.
- All right, Mike, thank you.
That was pretty exciting right?
So I went through a little
blue/green deployment of my own,
and I've got a surprise for you, Mike,
worked with Unicorn Watch folks
to get a new update on their streaming.
Let's go ahead and see how that works.
Oh, it worked on my machine,
so I'm not sure what's going on here,
but luckily we're using
blue/green deployment
so we can quickly roll back, if you will.
Hey, that looks better.
All right, so let's go through a couple
of the things of choosing
and also migrating between strategies.
So, first, changing them is really easy,
you can just change the strategy
in the deployment consideration,
as Mike talked about.
The key is adding that
advanced configuration,
if you're using a load balancer.
So once you've added that
advanced configuration
then you can actually go to
blue/green, back to rolling,
to Canary, to Linear, it's very fluid.
The key is that once you've
gone into advanced deployments,
we ask that you just leave
that advanced configuration there forever,
for as long as you're gonna use it,
because we could be using
either one of the target groups.
And so if you're doing a
rolling we need to have both
so that we can determine, hey,
this one's serving traffic,
or this one's serving traffic,
to do the rolling correctly.
So, again, add advanced configuration,
and then you're free
to move back and forth.
Also if you're, you have
kind of two different ways.
If you're wanting to migrate
from Code Deploy to ECS
deployment strategies,
you can either do just an update service,
so update in place,
and just move from both
deployment controller,
as well as deployment configuration,
to what you want it to be.
Again you'll need to add the
advanced configuration blocks,
and the load balancers all together
because if you're using Code Deploy
the load balancer configuration's
actually in Code Deploy land.
The other option is basically
make a replacement service,
and do that migration more
controlled in your way.
So if you wanna test out the hook,
if you wanna test out
the process a little bit,
you can just create a second service,
and then migrate.
Some of the considerations,
so we talked at the
beginning about sort of
how your tasks are scaling up and down,
and then also sort of
the speed or operation.
So your biggest trade off
from advanced configurations
and default rolling is kind
of that speed of rollback.
So you always have that
blue version fully scaled,
ready to go if for whatever reason
your service needs to scale up
during the middle of deployment,
both of them will scale
up to that capacity,
and it's always there.
So the speed of rollback is much higher,
obviously, in that scenario.
And then choosing between
your advanced deployment types
is really just what are
you trying to achieve?
If you want, hey, I only want one service
ever serving, or one revision, sorry,
ever serving traffic at
once, blue/green is perfect.
It makes sure that all
is served on the blue
or the green.
So that could be sometimes hey,
I have a very chatty client,
maybe a web app or something
that's making calls back and forth,
so to make sure they always
get a consistent experience,
I wanna use blue/green.
Canary, again, we talked
through that a little bit.
Some of that is if you
can't test in production,
maybe it's a regulated industry
or some other reason that you
cannot test in production,
Canary is a great way to introduce it
to a small section of your customer base
before introducing it to everybody.
And then finally Linear is a great option,
again, if you're interested
in seeing how it scales
under increased load over time,
or other sort of concerns
along those lines.
Again, one of the amazing things
that you can do with advanced deployments
is this test traffic.
So you have a means,
or you can test actual running code
in your production enviornment
before introducing it to
any of your customers,
and potentially preventing
an outage that way.
Again, as we talk about
you can migrate fluidly
between all of advanced deployments,
or between advanced
deployments and rolling.
Again, you can migrate Code Deploy
to advanced deployments,
and one of the reasons that
you might wanna do that
is to take advantage of some
of those advanced feature set
that you can use with ECS
that you couldn't before.
Mike talked through a couple of those.
Multi-target groups, sometimes if you have
multiple ALBs you're trying to connect to,
as well as using Service Connect
or some other features like that.
Finally, in order to
continue your journey,
we have a landing page here
with a bunch of relevant links,
as well as the actual deck
that we went through today.
Also there is a related
session this afternoon
at four in the MGM
covering deployment pipelines with ECS.
So if you wanna pop over to
there that would be great.
At this time I just wanna say
thank you very much for coming,
and I will be around here with Mike
if you have any questions afterwards.
Thank you.